Wolverine look at that Mel Gibson's
career is back ladies and gentleman oh
no no no that's just you Jack rented
come on
looks just like Mel Gibson third dude we
figured the Logan trailer was going to
look good but not good like this I
thought it was gonna be like x-men good
not oh my gosh the feels good there's
some surprises in here too at least for
me I'm sure people have the ear to the
ground on the rumor mill are probably
the actual factual synopsis I keep my
ear away from that [ __ ] I like being
surprised
so Logan's older and he's talking with
surprise to me Charles Xavier I thought
Days of Future past was going to be
Patrick Stewart's last romp as Charles
Xavier nope he's in Logan and Logan's
like the world's not like it was Charles
mutants rock on which makes me think is
he talking about mutants died in wars
and whatnot and he's one of the last
ones or is there some sort of airborne
pathogen that made mutation go away now
people who were meetings are now just
Homo sapiens you see scars on his back
and that one the same which makes me
think he doesn't have healing power
because healing power means no scar is
factually speaking that would mean that
so I really don't know it smell like
about this trailer it's neat gives you
the fields you have a cool Johnny Cash
song which really brings to light the
tone of what they're hopefully going for
granted you can take the biggest piece
of [ __ ] movie ever cut it together to
make a good-looking trailer it doesn't
really mean anything we're taking faith
here that this trailer is giving us the
tone and direction they're actually
going for the movie it was case [ __ ] man
let's bring on the fields Wolverine
however there's this little girl and
witch it's x-23 right I mean Xavier said
oh she's like you Logan she's very much
like you I'm gonna say she's x-23 unless
she's just hey maybe she's Sally the
orphan in a movie where they had an
opportunity to have x-23 and didn't take
it that would just be strange there's
also that scene where Wolverines
blocking someone's claws and it looks
like two spikes coming at em which might
be x-23 so basically Charles Xavier and
Logan reenact my two dads with x-23 and
11s I just like the fact that it takes
place in the x-men universe but it's not
super x-men defied it's just a very
personal story so it looks like do I
assume x-23 has escaped the sx
corporation that's them coming after her
and now Logan and Xavier together have
to help her Xavier probably dies because
of that scene right there
really doubt he's digging a grave and
looking all sad and heartbroken for the
love child of Draco Malfoy and the
Phantom Pain's I feel like he's gonna
die on dying or maybe it's like after
Charles Xavier dies it's like hey big
reveal this is actually the Last of Us
movie that's Joel and Ellie because holy
[ __ ] look yeah I mean the first half of
this trailer is the build-up that there
is to talk about the next half is a
montage with Johnny Cash music and
action sequences and the kalida holy
alright if you're gonna watch the
trailer watch the international trailer
why cuz of that oh yeah someone on my
Twitter thank you to you we related
watch the international trailer just
same one same makes all the difference
that Elijah does like alright this is
lock oh my god you took another [ __ ]
head as really good I will say if Logan
delivers on the tone and is as good as
the trailer is pitching it to be it will
be a fond bittersweet farewell to Hugh
Jackman as Wolverine this is supposed to
be his last film as Wolverine and I'm
gonna cry when I leave the theater
alright guys so the first trailer to
Logan have you seen it what did you
think about it really curious as to your
thoughts on this one whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
say more
[Music]